let me read it I'm going to break it
down but we're going to have to go in
depth because now you're going to learn
how to interpret scripture how not to
interpret scripture
okay this is Psalm 137 1-9 the Jews are
being taken into captivity to Babylon
now watch verse n is where the problem
lay you ready for
class you ready for
class I need you to focus Lord bless
numbers for your praise not for me amen
glory to the father all right now let's
go by the Rivers of Babylon so notice
they've been taken into captivity we sat
and wept when he remembered
Zion there on the poppers we hung our
Harps for there are captors asked us for
songs our torment tormentors demanded
songs of Joy they said sing us one of
the songs of Zion how can we sing the
songs of the Lord while in a foreign
land
heartbroken we're crushed you destroyed
Jerusalem in the temple we're now living
in Babylon you want us to sing oh
Jerusalem May my right hand forget its
skill may my tongue cling to the roof of
my mouth if I do not remember you if I
do not consider Jerusalem my highest Joy
remember oh Lord yahwah what the
are the sons of Esau
who hated the sons of Jacob because
Jacob and Esau were twin
brothers did on the day of Jerusalem
fell the rejoiced tear it down
they cried tear it down to to its
foundations oh daughter Babylon doomed
to destruction happy is he who repays
you for what you have done to us now
here's the Shocker he who seizes your
infants and dashes them against the
Rocks what this is
Bible this is
scripture an inspired author is saying
happy is he who takes infants Dash from
o and you tell me this is God's word you
understand Focus guys
Focus you with me there now we go into
meet I need you to
listen let me now explain and you're
going to see it's going to make sense
number one though the scriptures are
inspired that doesn't mean what God
inspires an author to write is
necessarily God's reflection okay let me
repeat this is where you need someone to
teach you how to properly interpret
scripture okay if you're not listening
you're going to distract me you're going
to distract each
other the Bible is inspired everything
Bible is inspired but you think because
it's inspired that somehow that means
this is God's thoughts no the
Bible is a collection of books inspired
by the spirit through human authors
where they're writing down what the
spirit wants them to write but not
everything they write down is from God's
perspective you with me
there you with me
there this is where wisdom maturity is
important so you can know when something
reflects the heart of God and something
reflects the individuals that God is
moving to speak and write okay I'm going
to show you examples of this that's
number one number
two at times God allows
permits things that he himself dislikes
and hates because of the condition of
the people he's engaging with let me
repeat it secondly God
allows permits tolerates things that he
himself dislikes or hates because his
people can't do any better can't go any
higher so patiently he puts up with them
and works through them to enable them
to rise to a higher
level you understand these two points
because I'm going to give you examples
let me show you examples where God is
inspiring a writer to write down what he
says without this being from God's
perspective you guys listening you're
going to get a lot of meat I don't think
they even teach this in Bible College I
don't know I'd be shocked if they're
teaching you this in your churches I'm
GNA give you examples you ready from
scripture we're going to come back
from scripture let me show you right
here let's go to Jeremiah 155 and 21 all
right and then we're going to go to 1
Corinthians 1 all right
10 to 17 watch Jeremiah 15:15 to
21 here watch now these words are
inspired meaning God is inspiring them
write these words down but these words
are written down
not so much because they're from God's
perspective because God is trying to
teach you through these
words the Christian Life the Christian
life will be full of misery pain
depression sadness anger joy peace and
love it's not a better of roses so here
you go Jeremiah 15:15 to 21 here you go
you who know y oh Yahweh now this is
Jeremiah remember me take notice of me
and take Vengeance for me on my
persecutors do not in view of your
patience Take Me Away know that for your
sake I Endure reproach because I
preached your words and I condemned
Sinners for their sin and told them
about your judgment they're now
insulting me they're threatening me they
hate me your words were found and I ate
them when you gave me your words I ate
them they became part of me and your
words became for me a join gladness in
my heart initially they did and this
this is the experience basically of all
the Christians all the Christians who
end up coming to the
faith and are on fire for their faith
even cradle Catholics Orthodox baptized
but you may not be on fire then at some
moment become fire and you're full of
joy and then you realize that honeymoon
phase dissipates doesn't it how many of
you can say there's a time I was on fire
and I wanted to move mountains but then
now reality kicked in that that's what I
call the honeymoon phase because
remember our relationship with God is a
husband to wife right Jesus is our
husband we are his bride and all of you
who date you know what I'm talking about
when you first meet that man man he's
like he you got butterflies in your
stomach and when you see him you blush
and your cheeks turn red like pepperoni
pizza and you can't look at him for too
long because your heart melts and then
later on in life you wake up like damn
what the hell did I marry same with the
men right you know what I'm talking
about you know what I'm talking about
come on now you know that come on guys
you who are
married right you are
married and the man like damn this woman
F she must be the eth Archangel come
down from
heaven couple years later Lord
is this what Purgatory is going to feel
like are you showing me what Purgatory
is going to be like because I feel like
I'm in purgatory because this woman
won't stop purging me you slay me slay
me woman
right all right same thing with the
Christian experience when you first come
to the Lord you're on fire and you're
ready to move mountains and you see God
everywhere and you said God's presence
and a couple years later you hit rock
bottom you're not as excited happy
anymore and now you're struggling to
endure welcome to the Christian Life and
here it is exemplified by
Jeremiah your words were found and I ate
them and your words became for me joy
and gladness in my heart for I've been
called by your name I am
called by
you and given your authority to speak on
your
behalf you have called me
made me your possession and your
spokesperson and I'm identified with you
oh Yahweh God of hosts I did not sit in
the circle of marry makers meaning I did
not keep company with Party Boys I
didn't hang out with dudes who went to
the bars or the nightclubs who got drunk
and got high and did drugs I stayed away
from that crowd see that
Christians nor did I exalt nor did I
party with them why cuz your hand upon
me your power was upon me you empowered
me to hate these things so I had to be
alone for you filled me with indignation
you filled me with righteous anger
against these things you with me there
get rid of the trolls
guys pay attention
please now watch here look at now the
point of misery look now he complains
look at Verse 18 watch here to
illustrate my
point why has my pain been perpetual and
my wound incurable refusing to be healed
why God all I've done is because of you
all this pain is because of you but I'm
still in pain and Agony now look what he
says to God will you indeed be to me
like a deceptive stream with water
that's unreliable
damn he dared speak this way to
God you see how miserable he
was he's saying to God because God said
he's the Fountain of Living Waters
Jeremiah 17:13 he goes hold on you said
to me you're the fountain Living Waters
but instead of being
refreshed and having my thirst quenched
I'm more miserable than before so did
you deceive me are you Waters that
failed me
damn do you see
that now did the Holy Spirit inspire
Jeremiah to write
that Focus Brethren did the Holy Spirit
Inspire Jeremiah to write that if the
spirit didn't tell him to write it then
why is it written and you're saying not
all of scripture is inspired of course
the spirit had him write it down because
if he didn't that means Jeremiah wrote
something that's not inspired so you
just said not all of the Bible is
inspired yes he did do you get it now
now just because the spirit has had him
write it down does that mean that the
spirit is agreeing with Jeremiah
no what the spirit is doing is having
Jeremiah write down how he honestly
feels about God without this being
something God approves of see this is
why you have to understand how
inspiration Works many people don't know
what inspiration means
and so now the
response therefore thus says
Yahweh
therefore thus says
Yahweh if you return then I will cause
you to repent return you see Jeremiah
was so far gone God is saying if you
repent he was in such a state of sin he
had to
repent return means repent if you return
then I'll cause you to return before me
you will stand if you repent then I will
restore you and you can be my Prophet
again if you extract the precious from
the worthless if you stop speaking
stupidly and speak what is right you
will become my mouthpiece you see how
far gone
Jeremiah
Was You Got It Marissa that's the point
now you're seeing the beauty and wisdom
of the spirit having these men be honest
with their emotions this is why God
hates fake
because now you can come for wow so I'm
not the only one I'm not the only one
who at times feels like God has
abandoned
me even the prophets felt that way wow
and God didn't destroy Jeremiah crushed
Jeremiah God understood Jeremiah's
plight and was patient with him that
means he'll be patient with
me
right all right no you're not seeing
where I'm with it Judah saw it 20
minutes
ago if you extract the precious from
worthless you'll become my mouthpiece
they for their part may turn to you you
must make them turn to your ways but as
for you you must not turn to them I will
make you to this people a fortified wall
of bronze you'll be unshakeable
unbreakable immovable and they will
fight against you but they will not PR
pril against you for I'm with you to
save you and deliver you declares Yahweh
so I will deliver you from the hand of
the evil ones and I'll redeem you from
the grasp of the ruthless ones
okay do you now understand how
inspiration Works doesn't
work okay I'm teaching you what
inspiration is and isn't now be honest
with me when's the last time you had
your church or your Bible College go
through this process of breaking down
scripture see Marissa now you see how
relatable the Bible is Marissa you see
how real the Bible is it is real
and the men were real and transparent
they did not hide and the spirit
inspired them to be real and upfront
with their
emotions okay that's why you pray for me
God gives me the health and the Holiness
safety I promise you all that I've
learned I will give to you until the
Lord summons me my duty will be
everything God has given me I'm going to
give to you before I die before I leave
this world I'm going to do my best to
give you all I have then you're going to
take it build on it improve it and Sh
teach it that is my service to you okay
now watch now you're going to learn
another thing God allowed and permitted
practices that he himself did not
approve because he was patiently putting
up with people who couldn't do any
better so now with that said we come to
Psalm
137 Psalm 137 all of that in the the
background now are you ready for Psalm
137 all of this was
Preparatory okay now let's read
carefully though see this is where
people don't read carefully we're going
to go back to my
article here's what people don't
understand number one oh daughter of
Babylon doomed to destruction happy is
he who repays you for what you have done
to us he who sees your infants and
dashes them against the Rocks okay
number
one notice it says happy is he who
repays you meaning what you've done to
us and the nations may be done to you
what do they do to the Nations well the
Babylonians and this is a fact of
archaeology and sadly All Nations that
went to war when they attack a place
they would rip open the wombs of
pregnant women they would take children
and dash them to the ground and kill
them without Mercy this is a fact so
what he's actually saying
is what you did to Others May be done to
you so you can get a taste of your own
medicine in other words he's invoking
eye for an eye tooth for a tooth here it
is Happy is he who repays you repays you
for what what you did what did they do
they would take pregnant women rip them
open and they would take children Dash
them to the grounds may you get a taste
of your own medicine he's invoking eye
for an eye tooth for a tooth show no py
life for Life eye for eye tooth for
tooth hand for
foot for foot you understand now what
he's doing it's called the
talionis the same thing you've done to
Others May it come upon you let me prove
it to you it's in your Bible here watch
what the nations would do not just the
Babylonians here 2 Kings 889-1133 look
what they would do the the
Babylonians here your Bible 2 Kings
89:13 hael went to meet Elisha
taking with him as a gift 40 camel loads
of all the finest wearers of Damascus he
went in and stood before him and said
your son Ben Hadad king of Adam has sent
me to ask Will I recover from this
illness
Elisha answered go and say to him you
will certainly recover but the Lord has
revealed to me that he will in fact die
how watch he stared at him with a fixed
gaze until H felt ashamed then a man of
God began to weep why is my Lord weeping
asked ha because I know the harm you
will do to the Israelites he answered
you will set fire to their fortified
places kill their young men with the
sword Dash their CH little children to
the ground and rip open their pregnant
women this was a way of life back then
sadly everyone got
it that's what the Babylonians did to
the Israelites and others here's another
one 10 13-
15 but you have planted wickedness you
have reaped evil you have eaten the
fruit of deception because you have
depended on your own strength and on
your many warriors the war of battle
will rise against your people so that
all your fortresses will be devastated
as shalman devastated Beth arul on the
day of battle when mothers were dashed
to the ground with their children this
was a way of life sadly
thus will it happen to you o bethl
because your wickedness is great when
that day Dawns the king of Israel will
be completely destroyed still not
convinced now chapter
3:10 yet she was taken captive when into
Exile her infants were dashed to pieces
at the head of her street Lots were cast
for Nobles and all her great men were
put in Chains even the Babylonians did
it here you go Isaiah 13 15 to
22 whoever is captured will be thrust
through all who are caught will fall by
the sword their infants will be dashed
to Pieces before their eyes so you see
what it's saying what you did
Babylonians will now be done to you what
you did Babylonians will be done to you
now the Nations will come they'll Dash
your infants to the ground before your
eyes their
houses will be be looted and their wise
ravished like you rape women your
women's going to get raped so I will
stir up against them the mes the meest
Persians who do not care for silver and
have no Delight in Gold their bows will
strike down the young men they have no
mercy on infants nor will they look with
compassion on children Babylon the jewel
of Kingdoms the glory of the Babylonians
Pride will be overthrown by God like
Sodom and Gomorrah she will never be
inhabited or lived in through all
generations no will pitch his tent there
no Shepherd will rest his flocks there
but desert creatures will lie there
jackals will fill her houses there the
owls will dwell and there the wild coats
will leap about hyenas will howl in her
strongholds Jackal in her luxurious
palaces her time is at hand her days
will not be prolonged now do you
understand what's going
on what the psalmist is
saying happy is he who repays you happy
who does to you what you have done to us
and the world those Nations you
conquered happy he is who takes eye for
the eye you
took right fracture for the fracture you
made tooth for the tooth you took and
injures you the way you injured others
that's what the psalmist is
saying you
understand you understand now what's
going
on it is saying may it be done to you
what you have done to others may you get
a taste of your own
medicine if you took out an eye may your
eye be taken out if you took out a tooth
may your tooth be taken out if you
fractured someone may it be done to you
the same thing you've done to others may
it happen to you okay that's what he's
saying but now let me show you
if you know your
archaeology if you know your
history you would know and I'm going to
show you I'm going to quot it okay
they're in Babylon right they're at
Babylon
right and the Babylonian Empire the king
of Babylon was in southern Iraq this is
a fact of
archaeology okay it says Dash them
against the Rocks right now let me show
you something that's shocking that I
learned from one of the greatest Old
Testament Scholars I think he's still
alive
Kaiser I met the man years ago an
outstanding scholar Protestant but
outstanding loves the
Lord may receive his road from the Lord
hold on one
second okay watch rocks right they're in
Babylon watch here to the shock of some
of you and I was shocked when I learned
it watch
here okay
here get ready to be shocked here you're
going to see it's not literal what do I
mean this brings me to my next Point
namely the psalmist is not literally
requesting the brutal deaths of children
how do I know but it's asking that
Justice be served in a poetic manner can
be easily seen from the phrase dashing
them against the Rocks Stones why get
ready as anyone familiar with Babylon
jar can tell you there were no rocks and
stones in
Babylon do you know that
Babylon at its height Southern Iraq had
no stones and rocks this is a fact of
archaeology and you think I'm lying here
Walter C Kaiser Jr the Old Testament
documents are they reliable and relevant
page 213 surely someone who goes about
stealing babies and slamming them down
in the pavement or over a rocky
embankment is more than a brute but this
is but is that what we have here not at
all for the expression is hyperbole
typical of the emotional near East
which consciously exaggerates the writer
however locates the psalm in Babylon one
thing Babylon is devoid of is rocks or
rock Rocky Cliffs this is so different
from Palestine where rocks are all over
the place but not in
Babylon if one were to build in Babylon
he would need to bake mud bricks first
rocks or Stones simply do not exist
there in your face
that tells you it's not
literal the psalmist is simply saying
eye for an eye tooth for a tooth what
you did may be done to you because he's
in Babylon and he knows there are no
rocks so you can't literally Dash
children against the
Rocks happy is he repays you for what
you have done to us he who sees their
infants and dashes them against the
Rocks see
see why I say the Bible in the wrong
hands is a dangerous
weapon and aren't you thankful the holy
spirit in his love and mercy for us when
I sought answers he revealed these
sources so I'm now revealing it to
you okay so it's not literal it's simply
the poetic way of saying I for an eye
tooth for an
tooth the punishment meets the crime